and this talk will be done by Camila
Cullen is about protecting interest s
words with Jupiter networks so come you
know when you want gonna stop okay thank
you so so I'm Camilo I work for Cisco
Systems but most of the content that I'm
going to explain today I also let's say
learn it from my previous job as a PhD
student in Institute in Madrid calling
their networks so I also should thank
them I think about doing interactive
dashboards in Jupiter that is putting
buttons and stuff so that you can play
with them and see changes okay so most
of you might have a reason why you want
to have interactivity in your onion your
Jupiter you might have a reason I will
argue that even in the most fancy
project you might also need this kind of
tool so let me let me try to set like a
problem statement so let us say that we
are in a project really nice project and
we're in charge of the process or
analysis of data this fancy project
usually well sometimes the output is
they have to so the end users are non
coders and they have to interact with
our project somehow so all with the
process that we're making maybe maybe
you need the end user to modify some
parameter of the process that you're
doing of the analysis they need to
trigger some operation or well stuff
like this so how can we offer a non
coder user interactivity into a
interactivity with our with our process
well there it is there are these very
fancy web frameworks some JavaScript
that things that now we have that
because 10 years ago everything was Java
and it was a pain but now we have that
they were very well and they're pretty
they're scalable well done but I don't
know if you have the experience on this
because to be well done they have truly
have to be tuned and tailor exactly for
the project that were in and that means
that maybe usually they are not going to
be done only until later stages of the
project so that's basically mostly at
the end part of the process
however I think we're going to have this
kind of system we also we need to have a
way in the early stages of the project
to have a a prototype let's say so for
many reasons for validation let's say
that probably the end-users are experts
on the field more than us and so we want
to see their feedback on what we're
doing so that we're doing correctly
maybe the one features the stuff like
this so prototyping having a prototype
of the UI is good however I mean I don't
know if you have to play with these
JavaScript UI I find it really painful
and it's really hard to hook our Python
pipeline with them I mean you might have
some way of doing it I don't it's kind
of hard so the problem that I have and I
try to coalesce to give you a way of
doing it the question that I have is how
can we build a prototype of a UI without
live in Jupiter there are other reasons
why you might need interactive dashboard
because of a proof-of-concept or so like
that but there are many reasons but this
is one that I like and I software let's
say so I'm going to view a proposal is
using well Jupiter we took their
notebooks I'm going to use a library
Calliope widgets is it comes from the
same also from the same group of Jupiter
plus another widget which is called
Jupiter matplotlib but basically allows
me to put figures in the wickets plus
another extension of Jupiter called
Jupiter dashboards that I will explain
later but basically lets you put the
cell outputs in different layouts on the
screen this is a proposal so bouquet
dashboards is also another alternative I
think for prototypes both of them were
well I just work with the first but if
you're feeling way better with bouquet
that's okay okay but let me just just
give you this introduction of these I
pipe widgets so basically I buy widgets
are they offer Jupiter ways of appending
HTML widget in your Jupiter notebooks so
the basic ones are you probably know so
but on text fields HTML box I say stuff
like this so one unfortunately cannot
see very well but let's say here I
besides importing the live
there's nothing more you have to do you
just describe it just create buttons you
create text and then they appear on the
screen they were like this not in fancy
so far okay what else the offer to meet
a killer application of a widget library
is our the layout widgets layout widgets
are basically widgets that allows you to
arrange other widgets on the screen the
I PI widgets have three of them their
boxes vertical and horizontal tabs on
accordion we're just going to play with
the first two here the key here or the
beauty of this is that layout widgets
can have all the layout with that our
children are children and so you can
basically do any let's say fancy layout
that you want as long as squares don't
never think about spheres but as long as
I don't see when a square type of layout
you can do it with this type of
hierarchy I have here an example so
before this cell I created a couple of
buttons a couple of texts in the first
line I'm creating a vertical box and I'm
putting one boat on a one text there in
the third line and creating a horizontal
box with another button and text and I'm
using a layout object of the same
library to basically extend it so it has
a bigger width and then I'm creating a
tap here tap object and I'm placing the
two other box there so well I mean
simple I mean the here the box with the
filled up the tab with the vertical box
and here's the the balls would develop
with the tab with the resort on box I
don't know if you already see it but
using this type of things you can
basically get any layer that you want
and I need simple so the complicated
part comes in the business intelligence
the intelligence of what you want your
things to do that not in conservatism is
on your own obviously the library offers
on some callbacks for for the widget so
you can actually do stuff with them I
basically use two callbacks for buttons
I use the click button and there's like
the generic callback call observe that
basically allows you to register which
function you want to recall when
specific traits of the widgets are
changed so when the user changes
something then you can then you can then
the function that you've registered is
called the traits of that which is might
differ but here what I did for instance
was so I created a couple of functions
this one for instance changes the text
and this disabled text every time that I
change the text on the on the text box
the text box gets disabled I mean
nothing super fancy but you see with
this you have the building blocks to
basically doing most of the basic stuff
okay so the I PI widget actually doesn't
come with a widget that allows you to
have figures and I don't know whether
we're in PI data we know that we have to
plot figures all the time there's this
library well there's this let's say
order that widget is a separ is separate
from the I PI widgets it's called
Jupiter matplotlib well this is a link
by the way the presentation isn't github
if you want to download it when you
import this library and is made by by
people active on the on the Jupiter on
the Jupiter project then you can
basically have matplotlib figures within
within the widget because what I want is
for them to play nicely with the layout
widgets because that's how I make my
prototypes so how it works is a mudblood
leap when you have a figure you have
figure and access right access are like
the children of the figures and but the
figures actually have like a parent
which is a canvas and the canvas depends
on the backend of the mat load live that
you that you select that I mean it is
how imported so what must this Jupiter
muscle lead library does is it it makes
the canvas be a widget so that's how it
plays like there's another library
called BQ plot I actually it's made from
the same guys of duty that metal lip I
think thanks to them in the distance
they don't know me but thanks
they kept that one is a lot another
alternative but I don't know how how how
it works so I'm just going to go with
this one here ok so just an example so
here I'm creating a figure first line
I'm selling its own size and then create
a couple of buttons that clean the
figure or draw something silly on there
on it and what I want to show you
actually is that
the good part is that the canvas becomes
kind of a widget so I can put it within
a layout widget in this case a silly eh
box and if I want it I could have I
could put that box into a tab and I
could put that tap into another tab and
stuff like this so this is the beauty of
these widgets okay the other element
that I told you is Jupiter dashboards
there's nothing really fancy about it so
basically we are going to come to this
at the end but basically what it lets
you is that it lets you our so the
output of this for Easterns of this
notebook I mean this is a log notebook
but long and what the jute and what the
dashboard allows is basically to be able
to place the output of the cells in a
specific grids so you can move the sizes
and you can place the outputs in
different layouts nothing really fancy
but it really works well for a prototype
if you want to get your message come
back and that's it I mean there's
nothing more about it so but but it's
powerfully build okay so why is work for
me or why is working on my job basically
this is far from idea from project from
product I mean if you come to me and you
tell me I'm going to create a product
based on this I'm gonna tell you a lot
easier people crazy because it's not
really super duper perfect but
prototypes work great works great it's
relatively simple
it offers what you need I mean text you
can show with the text boxes with the
HTML I grabs with the matplotlib that
I'll show you on tables pandas now the
data frames have this style option I
think it came out of all versions ago
and it lets you have the out point in
HTML is very flexible and together with
the HTML widget you can basically have
the you can basically have your tables
look nice actually we still need a
better data frame widget I say so that
we have more interactivity with the
tables I think the bouquet dashboard
actually has one that is a bit better by
having play with it but in case you want
to check it out and it worked for me and
I've been telling you that because of
the level approach so the point is this
is that many of these widgets
so they layered widgets allows you to
make arrangements of widgets in very
flexible way but also because we did our
object you can actually pass them or
return them from function so one of my
recipes let's say is if I need certain
layouts of widgets to be to be made
dependable on options of an options that
the user has then what I have is that I
have the construction behind a function
that takes parameters I create within
the function
all the widgets that I need to make on
the order that that I need them to be
according to the input parameters I'm
then I return basically the parent
object the parent layout object and they
and then I can use that in any other way
so it's a way of extracting a lot of
code and so it makes it very clean and
finally the dashboard is like the cherry
on top that allows me to have everything
very flexible in the screen and very
honestly I will tell you that this is it
and the 30 criticality radical part with
these elements I think you can fit a
train sideways and you can do much of
the things that you want as one of their
prototypes I would say so let me give
you a toy example I'm a network engineer
I love my networks I am going to be a
bitten commit this misleading so
networking is a big field but here I'm
going to talk a bit of how a toy example
of trying to explore the entire traffic
of a big I speak a weak Internet service
provider because I have to talk about
network then I'm going to give an
introduction on how the internet works
just for the sake of it
so I know how I don't need to know how
the internet works so basically the
Internet is this map this engagement or
of networks of networks we have around
55k of them they are called autonomous
system actually as a technical term you
and me we are not networks of these
we're not networks on the internet we're
just users of a single network
universities like this sometimes they
are not networks i mean sometimes they
actually behave like us they are just
clients behind a single network so for
you to be a network you need to go to
get a number a bit of Governments a bit
of politics and then and then you can
and if you want but if you want to join
if you want to connect to the internet
you actually have to connect to other
networks I make arrangement with them
and this is the most capitalistic
process in the world I mean there's
nothing I mean the internet worse pure
business there's no nothing so said no
everything is business in the internet
so if I need connectivity then one way
that I can do is I can go to another
network and tell them ok I pay you and
you give me transit and so you you pay
the money and then you become let's say
customers of them and they do they
basically follow all what all they give
you the chance at traffic that they have
for you and and they deal with the
traffic that you send that's a way of
connectivity the other typical one is
called Salem and free peering and
basically when I knowing it in my
traffic when I see this is the visitor
topic of this or this toy example when I
see that I have a lot of traffic to
another network and I'm not connected
directly to them I can go to them and
tell them lick Carlos so we have a lot
of traffic with each other let's connect
and Carlos says ok and so you arranged
maybe where you have to put the cable
remember everything your cables you
don't want wireless here so you connect
the cable somewhere you have to see
which building and that's it and then ok
then you have a connection the internet
10 years ago was dominated by the
customer transit type of links so it was
very polemical so something like this
now is more dominated by the peering
link so it's more flat there's just
phd's about that we want to go in to
check it ok so let's say we have a
connection already so we have a link and
the question is ok how can I tell you
which networks can you can reach through
me so that's why we use the VDP protocol
which is the core of the internet let's
say so if you basically tell the other
networks what you can reach through you
and you receive how we receive the
networks that you can that you can reach
if you send them the traffic as with
mostly most routing protocols you have
to know that digital routing protocols
usually because that leads to
instability
do not lead with congestion so they
don't have congestion of the links or
poor capacity on their algorithms so
it's up to the operator let's say
to be able to move the traffic and in
such a way that the links are healthy
they're not that they have yet that they
are not congested this is typically
called traffic engineering okay all of
this will be kind of important for for
the actual example so what we have let's
say what we have is a fictitious that I
said that I built let's say educated
fictitious that I said that I build for
a fake transit provider that is
connected to six different networks
let's hold these words but is not that
pretty but it the model is class
whatever I really want to show this
address so what we have is we have a big
data frame it has so for every for every
let's say row we have a destination and
a source net I hope you can see it so
that's an IP version 6 address I hope
you recognize them if you don't and if
you ever have to write code to deal with
IP addresses please make sure that your
code deals with both the typical IP
version 4 ones and the IP version 6 ones
Python has the has this IP address
library made for Google in Python 3 is
there so try to use it it'll be slow but
it will deal with it it will be 3d for
you it will dip for the net and it will
deal with the nervous for you
okay so this thing doesn't go that way
finally so there's a source destination
router source destination is egress and
ingress link but actually getting this
information is the hard part and that's
actually my job to try to get that
information and to put it in this nice
way but I did the hard work for you ok
so let's see what is the use case what
do we have to do with this data so we'll
let let's just just try to provide an
operator with a way of exploring it so
they can make decisions such as the one
that I said before which networks should
i pair with or stuff like this and
second of all let's try to be fancy and
let's say at least to provide some
functions of load balancing so let's try
to provide a way to tell the operator
look I exchanged the traffic like this
so you can have the run balance in the
network the workflow that I will propose
for this I so
I tend to I tend to like to have this I
think I like the divided and group
approach which I call which is basically
when you have a data set with a lot of
features a lot of characteristics and
you need to explore it I like to first
provide users with a filtering approach
so that they know exactly what they want
so that they say this is what I want to
explore first and then I like to believe
options of grouping on the different
characteristic so they see what what's
going on so this is what we're going to
do here so first I'm going to offer in
widget a way for operators to filter
what kind of traffic they want to
actually see and second I'm going to
divide the traffic into three sides for
a reason the first side I'm going to let
them explore the whole thing that they
filter second I'm just going to focus on
the ingress traffic then I'm going to
focus on the egress traffic so that they
can explore those two and more
importantly and I'm going to focus on
ingress and egress because they
load-balancing depend so the load
balancing is a specific for egress or
for ingress so I'm going to do that
before let's say that because the
traffic is basically a time series then
it makes sense to have a let's say kind
of widget and is not really a widget is
an arrangement of widgets that lets you
explore this time series what this
widget will do but this is kind of a bi
expediency when you have a time series I
usually like to explore it first by
looking at the behavior in time using a
figure but I also like to see like
numbers using a table ignoring the time
so basically having the mean or the sum
because with the numbers I can I get
some information from the numbers and
from the figure I get that we have year
in time I also don't like to see
thousands of flows or thousands of time
series on my own my figures because that
basically doesn't give you anything but
if you but I know that if you select
your data will usually follow the rule
of nineteen ninety ninety ten that means
usually ten percent of the flows they
have 90 percent of the traffic at least
and on the internet and so basically I'm
going to show not everything but I'm
going to chop those the top contributors
so I did this already
so what I did was under code is in the
in the github but what I did was
basically create this figure this news
of this function
given a specific data frame I basically
tell it which is the code in the data
frame which column is the time but if
the time on that time series which
column is the value that are the time
series then it takes that all the rest
are characteristics of the time series
and I also tell it if I want a widget
that is vertically aligned or
horizontally aligned what it does is
well certainly doesn't see so well but
you have here all the positive using
which you want to group and a button to
to update I don't like to do automatic
stuff I'll actually like to buttons
because if not then the whole notebook
my get crazy so for instance if I wanted
to see just the egress link division of
the traffic then what happens is when I
update the button the figure gets
refreshed so this is what I told you
that I like to see the numbers on a
table and I like to see the behavior in
time with a graph but this contains me
some information is convince me another
and this is a function so I can actually
give it as many data emphasize one and
they will be and this thing will be
created and it returns a widget so I can
put this widget in other widgets and
that's it so let me tell you at the end
what I did based on this workflow how I
unfortunately it doesn't look so good
but so basically here on this box here
let me go to the actual preview so in
the box here we are basically allowing
the operator to select which traffic
they want to see so maybe they want to
see only the traffic for a specific
autonomous systems or specific neighbor
and neighbors or they want to see the
traffic on a specific valtor's so let us
just see I know this this one so when I
press this button it takes the big data
frame it filters just for the for the
traffic of that is and it repopulate
these with that the the resulting data
frames here I can explore the whole
traffic and the beauty here is that here
I can explore I remove basically where I
group over the egress links only so I
can focus on that and if I see if I see
here this neighboring is has three
different links one in front for when
you answer that one in Barcelona and the
traffic in Amsterdam is a bit bigger and
if you see the difference in
in traffic are big and happens that if
you if the operator decides because of
the their policy that it is the same for
them to send traffic in front for
Barcelona or Amsterdam
then what you can do is that you can try
to move traffic across the links because
I mean it's the same destination so this
is what this was the second use case of
the of the of this toy example so here I
have another widget which basically
incorporates these load balancing
algorithm that I did it works perfectly
because this example but what idea is
the same so basically from this input it
this things that it thinks moves it's a
prototype nobody cares but if in a real
in a real dashboard they will try
pickled people crazy
so here's here the drilling this is the
resulting and it actually tells you how
you will get the thing on the right so
it tells your parada ok so if you want
this you have to change if you had to
change the traffic of this network to a
link in Amsterdam because obviously the
leaking astern is lower and then you can
do a lot of these small changes and you
get the thing on the right for to do
this algorithm I basically ignore time
because doing the balancing with the
time dimension is a pain it's even hard
to define so I just ignore time I just
say the sums of all the characteristics
on the period and then I do kind of a
heuristic to move I move element until I
get until I minimize the standard
deviation of the of the whole thing ok I
could do the same with the ingress
actually the ingress will look well I'm
not going to do a time to see how it
looks ok it looks different I could also
try to do the load balancing as a bonus
ID I couldn't finish but as a bonus I
also wanted to try to show you how an
operator could work with router
configuration rotor configuration is
like the Holy Grail right now of
networking because you see there are a
lot of vendors including employer and
and all of them they have their own ways
of configuring the routers and right now
as an industry more we're trying to move
to let's say common models and these
common models are very nice they're in
JSON or well you can get the
confirmation in JSON a standard way so
to do this I actually try to do
kind of a JSON navigator that will get
the JSON configuration of the routers
and allowed the operator to to go over
the JSON I kind of thought of this map
when the Mac goes into the files it has
this kind of which you can go
hierarchies of folders using Windows so
I wanted to reproduce that so okay
that's an were so well yet but but this
is all done by widgets and I think it's
kind of fancy although not super but but
you can do that with widgets so message
widget if you spend enough time you can
do kind of nice stuff okay so that is
actually most of it I just got a final
conclusion that I really I mean my final
completion is at least if we're doing
prototypes the what the perfect is the
enemy of the getting things done so
these libraries and I'm pretty sure
bucket two and other libraries that are
say traps hooks into JavaScript they
probably will drive you crazy if you
want to get everything right I still
don't know how to make the bottom font
bigger I can make a bit on the size of
the screen I can I don't know how to
make the button from bigger I don't know
if it's feasible I haven't seen in a
stack overflow so I haven't I don't know
I haven't done it and I don't know if
you can do it so and that will be a pain
if it's a really see if it's a end
product but for a prototype is perfectly
fine so I will tell you if you're doing
prototyping just spend enough time that
you convey your message but do not do
not exaggerate because it's not that
good for your room for your health okay
so just two things to finish why I
wanted to talk about networking but I
needed to talk about Python actually so
if you guys are in Barcelona we have an
SDN lit up so we have a networking
meetup is called software-defined
networking Meetup
we're not that many if you are
interested in that working please come
we'll be happy to have you
yeah that's on one side the second side
is that if you actually want to so this
is our toy example if you actually
want to explore time-series there are
these products called well this projects
called Cabana Andrea fauna they're
really nice use them do not use but
don't reinvent the wheel I mean they are
very good for the exploration side
although if you actually wanted to do
that router configuration or that or
that or that dog balancing easy widget
you will 'extra because everything is in
JavaScript and things so yeah that's it
actually
[Applause]
thanks thanks on Camilla for these
amazing presentations any questions
thank you is there is there any way to
share the dashboard with users that
don't have anaconda installed and Iowa
is so you you you develop the dashboard
yes a and is there any way to share it
with people inside of organizations that
don't have anaconda in salt or Jupiter
what I don't know converse with well
there was a talk about Jupiter in the
clouds maybe I don't know if it supports
extensions because we will need the
dashboard extension if you want is one
Ds that will delete the solution that
comes in top of my head are usually on
these prototypes well what I think is
that you go into a meetings and then you
can show with your computer in a more
relaxed way or you share your screen so
but but yeah I opposed it this I didn't
actually have gone to that but maybe
that that is the solution that really
cool about it thanks for questions
hello thanks for today for the
presentation actually is not a company
size and I sign questions that comment
and Twitter is a tool to share your
local projects through a secure way in
Internet as we can talk afterwards if
you want and there's a project is called
Newark and it's typically used for that
I mean to share so local project to
someone through Internet in a secure way
more questions I have one one question
when you are dealing with this data and
the data is already on memory or you can
you can connect to databases in a
synchronous way example well no this one
is in memory to connect to have
something like a streaming or something
like that it we will need something more
fancy but as long as it's in data in the
data frame in a data frame remember you
can you can work out you will have to
figure out the other part of there so
actually in one of my in one of my
projects I do have some pies part doing
something and then having some remote
calls to get the data and update the
widgets but I do update it with a button
it is not like fancy things moving
without you I tend to like more triggers
in prototypes and dumb things and move
on their own but it could be run with
research well I did I did something yes
yeah more questions then let's sang
[Applause]